determine the domain and range of the
function f of x is equal to 3x squared
plus 6x minus 2. so the domain of the
function is what is the set of all of
the valid inputs or all of the valid x
values for this function and i can take
any real number square it multiply it by
3 then add 6 times that real number and
then subtract 2 from it so essentially
any number for talking about reals when
we think about any number so the domain
the set of valid inputs the set of
inputs over which this function is
defined is all real numbers
so the domain here
is all real numbers
all
all real
numbers
and for those of you who might say well
you know aren't all numbers real you you
may or may not know that there is a
class of numbers that are a little bit
bizarre when you first learn them called
imaginary numbers and complex numbers
but i won't go into that right now but
most of the traditional numbers that you
know of they are part of the set of real
numbers it's pretty much everything but
complex numbers so you take any real
number and you put it here you can
square it multiply 3 then add 6 times it
and subtract 2. now the range at least
the way we've been thinking about it in
this series of videos the range is the
set of possible the set of possible
outputs of this function or if we set y
equals f y equal f of x on on a graph is
a set of all the possible y values and
to get a flavor for this i'm going to
try to graph this function right over
here and if you're familiar with
quadratics and that's what this function
is right over here it is a quadratic you
might already know that it has a
parabolic shape and so it's shape might
look something like this and actually
this one will look like this it's upward
opening but other parabolas have shapes
like that and you see when a parabola
has a shape like this it won't take any
it won't take on any values below its
vertex when it's upward opening and it
won't take any values take on any values
above its vertex when it is downward
opening so let's look at let's see if we
can graph this and maybe get a sense of
its vertex there are ways to calculate
the vertex exactly but let's see how we
can how we can think about this problem
so i'm going to try some x and y values
there's other ways to directly compute
the vertex
negative b over 2a is the formula for it
it comes straight out of the quadratic
formula which you get from completing
the square but let's try some x values
and then let's see what f of x is equal
to
so let's try well this the values we've
been trying in the last few videos what
happens when x is equal to negative 2
then f of x is 3 times negative 2
squared which is 4
plus 6 times negative 2 which is
6 times negative 2 so it's minus 12
minus 2. so this is 12 minus 12 minus 2
so it's equal to negative 2.
now what happens when x is equal to
negative 1.
so this is going to be 3 times negative
1 squared which is just 1
minus
or i should say plus 6 times negative 1
which is minus 6
and then minus 2
and then minus 2. so this is 3 minus 6
is negative 3 minus 2 is equal to
negative 5 and that actually is the
vertex and you know
the formula for the vertex once again is
negative b over 2a so negative b that's
the coefficient on this term right over
here it's negative 6 over 2 times this
one right over here 2 times 3.
2 times 3 this is equal to negative 1.
so that is the vertex but let's just
keep on going right over here so what
happens when x is equal to zero these
first two terms are zero you're just
left with a negative two
when x is equal to positive one and this
is where you can see that that this is
the vertex and you start seeing the
symmetry if you go one above the vertex
f of x is equal to negative two if you
go one x value below the vertex or below
the x value of the vertex f of x is
equal to negative two again but let's
just keep going
we could try let's do one more point
over here so we have we could try x is
equal to one when x is equal to one you
have three
times one squared which is one so three
times one plus six times one which is
just six
minus 2. so this is 9 minus 2 it's equal
to 7. and that
i think is enough points to give us a
scaffold of what this graph will look
like what the graph of the function
would look like
so it would look something like this let
me do my best to draw it
so this is
x equals negative two let me draw the
whole axis this is x is equal to
negative one this is x is equal to
this is
x is equal to 0 and then this is x is
equal to 1 right over there and then
when x is equal to we go from negative 2
all the way to positive
or we should go from negative 5 all the
way to positive 7. so let's say this is
negative 1 2
3 4 5
that's negative 5 over there on the y
axis
y axis and then let me go to positive 7
1 2
3 4
5 6
7. i could keep going this is in the y
and we're going to set y equal to
whatever our output of the function is y
is equal to f of x and this is 1 right
here
so let's plot the points you have the
point negative 2 negative 2
when x is negative 2 this is the x axis
when x is negative 2
y is negative 2.
y is negative 2. so that is that right
over there
so that is the point that is the point
negative 2 comma negative 2 fair enough
then we have at this point we have this
pink or purplish color negative when x
is negative 1 f of x is negative 5. when
x is negative 1 f of x is negative five
and we already said that this is the
vertex and you'll see the symmetry
around it in a second so this is the
point negative one
negative five
and then
we have the point zero negative two
zero negative two when x is 0
y is negative 2
or f of x is negative 2 or f of 0 is
negative 2. so this is the point 0
negative 2. and then finally when x is
equal to 1 f of 1 is 7. f of 1 is 7. so
that's right there is the point
1 comma 7. and it gives us a scaffold
for what this parabola what this curve
will look like so i'll try my best to
draw it respectably
so it would look something
something like that and keep on going in
that direction keep on going in that
direction but i think you see the
symmetry around the vertex that if you
were to if you were to put a line right
over here the two sides are kind of the
mirror images of each other there you
can flip them over and that's how we
know it's the vertex and that's how we
also know because this is an upward
opening parabola i mean there are
formulas for vertex and there are
multiple ways of calculating it
but since it's an upward opening
parabola the vertex is going to be the
minimum point this is the minimum value
that the parabola will take on so going
back to the original question this is
all for trying to figure out the range
the set of y values the set of outputs
that this function can generate you see
that the function it can get as low as
negative five it got all the way down to
negative five right at the vertex but as
you go to the right as x values increase
to the right or decrease to the left
then the parabola goes upwards so the
parabola can never give you values f of
x is never going to be less than
negative 5. so our domain but it can
take on all the valves you can keep on
increasing forever as x gets larger x
gets smaller away from the vertex so our
range here so we already said the domain
is all real numbers our range the
possible y values is
all
real
numbers
all real numbers
greater than or equal to negative five
it can take on the value of any real
number greater than or equal to negative
five nothing less than negative five